michael santana streams league of
legends to almost
20 000 viewers every day
he's on a self-motivated quest to become
the best
ad carry in north america you guys want
me to add a little bit of the flame
maria
for flame arena you guys suck
there we go a light peppering dude
he makes over 1.5 million dollars
every year from the comfort of his own
living room alongside his trusty
sidekicks
small cat and mellow i love
league of legends i
love league of legends he's a cutie pie
and this is his story
i'm a cutie pie here ladies and
gentlemen ladies
ladies and gents what do you what do
people say to make like funny jokes
michael i'm a cutie pie santana's
professional league of legends career
started in 2011 right around the time
that the lcs was being formed
he was recruited by william scara lee to
join his team
rock solid as they're starting 80 carry
soon after they formed the team finished
fourth at the national esl
premier league in 2011 and were picked
up by dignitas
dig's initial lineup consisted of boy
boy in the top lane
jat in the jungle scara in the mid lane
and ima cutie pie and locust in the bot
lane
their first event under the dignitas
banner was a massive success
as they defeated curse gaming clg and
epic gamer
to win ign premier league season three
this could be it for epic dyrus going
down quite quickly double kill
and it's going to be a take down there
the mid turret is gone
they will be able to go straight for
these nexus turrets and it looks like
they may be able to take the game right
clean out of the hands of epic who came
out with the first
awesome game the surrender comes out
from epic and dignitas will be able to
take ipl3 origins
as your champions the win helped
establish digg as a legitimate contender
in north american
league of legends this was a time when
na's competitive league of legends scene
was a far cry from the structured
franchise league it is today
to compete at the highest level teams
had to drop the rest of their
responsibilities
and devote their lives to the game in
order to become relevant
and often unsuccessful trips to
tournaments were a net loss
financially so initially it was really a
gamble
because a lot of us were doing it out of
passion and there was actually almost no
revenue streams
so there was a point in time where it
cost
more to travel to cologne for esl's
events
than it did to win third place
so you had to place second or first to
actually get your money back for
traveling like all the way from north
america to cologne
so when digg bound out of iem new york's
2012 group stage
it was a big deal they're going to jump
in for some more that will fall lambie
is still alive
wow doing so much damage kills scar on
the platform
fnatic will go 3-0 in the group they are
definitely moving on to the next day
and like i said they do it on land all
day every day fnatic yeah
looking strong today dignitas saw season
two as an opportunity
to become a force in the scene they
placed third at iem
kiev which helped them qualify for the
iem 6 world championship
where they lost to moscow 5 in the
finals
cutie's performance in kiev was
impressive posting a 4.17 kda
while averaging 4.88 kills per game
throughout the tournament
has been charmed whoa oh my gosh the
damage i think the damage a little bit
they're going to dive towards bk
picking's going to surely get caught out
he will do goes down in a bunch of sushi
also taken down and that has gone very
badly
staying behind his tanks doing a very
nice job of poisoning and just miasma
and everything
and they are just systematically taking
out bananas quite away the damage and i
think cute spy may well get the kill on
towards genji here he's trying to
lifesteal through it will manage to take
him down flash through
aside from i'm a cutie pie's stable
presence in the bot lane
team dignitas roster was a bit of a
revolving door
jat stepped down late in 2011 and was
replaced with i will dominate early in
2012.
crumbs was picked up to fill the hole
left in the top lane by voyboy's
departure
throughout his career ima cutie pie was
one of the only members of dignitas
that wasn't in and out of the lineup and
acted as a stabilizing presence
for a lineup that was constantly in flux
team dignitas were still finding
themselves as a team at the end of
season 2
and into 2013. i will dominate left and
crumbs went back to the jungle
while kiwi kid was signed on to be the
team's new top laner
that core along with cutie pie would
eventually become
the team's backbone ahead of the north
american lcs's
inaugural season season three for me is
is the first step that riot takes to
make this game be like a real sport
and so there'll be a lot of eyes on this
first season the creation of the north
american league of legends
championship series saw eight teams from
the region
compete in a structured league that was
loosely modeled off of traditional
sports leagues ladies and gentlemen
today is the day
the official start of the league of
legends championship series
this is a groundbreaking moment in
league history as eight north american
teams take their first steps
on the way to the summoner's cup for
cutie pie the nalcs was a chance to
prove himself among the region's best
players every week
in the beginning the lcs didn't have an
identity
and each of the eight participating
teams were quite different from one
another
you had the likes of counter logic
gaming and team solomid
established organizations that had
amassed massive fan bases
and teams like vulcan who were new to
the scene and looking to make a name for
themselves
and then there was dignitas who were
somewhere in the middle
sometimes goofing around yesterday oh my
troubles seemed so
far away but
now i eat something
sometimes wowing on stage
and puts themselves into the season
three championship series
dignitas were the lcs team that most
resembled
a bunch of friends who were just hanging
out and playing league of legends
at an extremely high level after taking
baron dignitas would push their way to
the nexus with little resistance
they became the first team in the lcs to
defeat curse snapping their eight-game
winning streak
there we go they kill the nexus and dig
the toss have ended curses undefeated
streak
you guys smile so much like you're such
a happy team is that one of the reasons
you've been able to come around with
this like awesome win streak because you
guys get along so well
dignitas started their lcs run with a
whopping
16 and 5 record in their first 21 games
of the spring split
and cutie pie proved that he was a top
tier north american 80
carry he was the second in the league in
kda
behind sneaky and his cs average was
second only to doublelift
diggs stumbled at the end of the season
going one and six in their final
seven games to finish the season with a
17 and 11
overall record coming up on the back
side it looks like they'll be able to
take down the nexus as well
clg will be able to take down dignitas
in game six of super week wednesday
they were then immediately booted from
the playoffs by good game universe
evaporated right now down to 300 health
nintendo with us him again but they go
over the nexus they get it
don't ask me is unstoppable and the
nexus goes down ginger eubie stick the
toss in the playoff
the team's volatility continued into the
summer split
where they started the season six and
two but finished
13 and 15 narrowly avoiding relegation
heading into the 2014 season
kiwi kid moved from top lane to support
and the team signed cruiser the bruiser
this move marked an important moment in
i'm a cutie pie's career
and was the peak of cutie's competitive
prowess as a north american ad
carry i mean it's like bad as it is to
say i'm never worried about any team
like i know if i just like play my game
like
i'm better than them
but there's a big wave here oh that's
the flash and the headbutt back
but they get a good push kiwi kid comes
in from the back side and this is the
requiem strategy
trying to get the kill down but they're
able to turn it back no kiwi kid lives
in this one
crumbs gets the kill the first blood
going over there
now cutie pie gets a kill but neon turns
it back around
it's 2v1 on the end really be able to
get one more kill with the ultimate
going off
it's not going to be enough the double
kill for cutie pie
at this time dignitas was actually
looking to get rid of kiwi from the
roster entirely
the original plan was to just remove him
from the team completely but i'd
actually
asked our manager to keep kiwi on the
team
to making my support like i took kiwi
from
top lane barely playing support into the
support that he is now and honestly i
think he became a great support
2014 saw more of the same from dignitas
the team finished 12 and 16 during the
season
placing fourth overall the year was
marred by roster shuffling as both
shifter and zion spartan joined the team
while scarra popped in and out of the
lineup
dignitas would take fifth place in the
playoffs it's like we have we've always
had problems with the team
that have like stopped us from being
like as good as we could be
like i honestly feel like the people we
have
we could be the best it's just our
mentality is
terrible it turns out when you're
competing on a national stage with four
of your best friends
and everyone gets along complacency can
set in
and it's that complacency that i'm a
cutie pie would eventually capture
as his on-stream persona and i just
pop the [ __ ] up
we should have popped
[Music]
that's right cutie pie was able to make
not giving a crap
a full-time dedicated and lucrative
business
you shouldn't feel intimidated because
it's called the big big club dude
because everyone's got a big dick
right here in their heart
but professionally cutie understood that
the lcs
was going through a transition i wasn't
meshing well with the scene
with where i was going because when i
got into league
is completely different than how it is
now more money was flowing into the
league
and the pressure for teams to perform
was greater than ever
organizations began to tinker with their
rosters in search of more wins
breaking up their stalwart players in
favor of super teams
this is something cutie quickly realized
he couldn't be a part of
if he couldn't play with his friends he
couldn't play in the lcs
i love this team i [ __ ] couldn't
stand if we got
anyone else or if i was on another team
because jesus christ
[ __ ] people like this team's
great i love them that's why i want this
to work
in october 2014 ima cutiepie announced
that he would not
be resigning with dignitas so for me
league has always been something that's
just super fun i am competitive by
nature
definitely and i always strive to do my
best to win
but i've never had it in me to
cut players for underperforming and
things like that
cutie knew he still had the competitive
drive to play
so he took that drive and put it towards
his stream
since making the jump from the lcs stage
to his living room chair
cutie has embraced the lackadaisical
attitude he criticized dignitas for
and adopted it into his personal
streaming brand
he was always known for his charismatic
approach to the game
even on stage and now he's turned that
attitude
into a day job watching cutie stream
is an 8 hour long amalgamation of
professionalism
you know people were telling me cutie
pie i don't think your stream
is professional enough i'm gonna wear a
suit
every day i stream now and
self-deprecating humor
oh my [ __ ] god i missed that oh i'm
so trash he's gonna kill him though
and he's gonna hit level six off that
and kill me right
this that's the standard play right
there he pulls your emotions in two
directions
first he reels you in with his
staggering streaming consistency
huge viewership numbers and high solo
queue skill level
then he keeps you coming back for his
random tantrum tantrum-like
outbursts and fun-first approach to
playing league of legends
everyone's failed one time or another
i'm gonna let you in on a secret dude
this is between me and you i failed too
and you know what that hasn't stopped
man this failure
is only the beginning the beginning to
the end
that is success [ __ ] set the [ __ ] up
he's
out because that's what a man's gotta do
tim come on man
that's what a man does what a man does
is he
he handles his business he's me
[ __ ] twitch dan don't talk about it
be about it
you know what i'm saying tim knows what
i'm talking about
you got pranked bro
i'm a cutie pie zero talk all action
that's why i'm a cutie pie's herald as
the greatest
cutie takes every classic nerd
stereotype and
wields them as a means to his success
his ungroomed aesthetic and everyday
outfit of basketball shorts and a white
tee make him look more like the person
your parents warned you you'd become
if you didn't give up gaming than a
millionaire
what's most interesting is how
self-aware he is about all of this
what best exemplifies this is his
ongoing virtual feud with team liquid's
doublelift
michael santana
holy [ __ ] huge fan
cutie has routinely flamed na's most
famous pro
a.d carey challenged him and claimed
that
he is the superior player do i have a
rhetoric yeah
i don't know i i have no idea what to
say i could if i every time i see him
solo queue
he can't even stand up to me man
i can anybody every time i see him in
solo queue he said he beats me
me it's solo cute you don't beat me in
solo cute dude
i i can't cry every time i sit down solo
queue
this david versus goliath style feud
shows just how relevant cutie is to the
league of legends community
the joke has reached as far as the lcs
stage and stokes the fires of twitch
chat
whenever doublelift competes i've heard
some rumors going around that the real
reason that you are back in the north
american lcs is to avoid running into
cutie pie and solo queue can you provide
me with whether or not there's any truth
to that
dude i was ranked higher than pewdiepie
for like five months and then one time
the one time that he's high ranked in me
he like has to rub in my face but
no cutie pie is boosted garbage
even four years after his last lcs game
cutie's popularity still rivals some of
the game's best
smartcat what are you meowing about it's
been almost four years since i'm a cutie
pie left dignitas
in that time he's accrued more
viewership on twitch than
any other league of legends streamer he
streams to almost
20 000 viewers each day around 50 hours
a week
and has more than 2 million followers
cutie did make a short return to the
rift in professional league of legends
with delta fox in the summer of 2017.
the team was comprised of five notable
streaming personalities
and competed in the n a challenger
series as a subsidiary
of lcs team echo fox i'm a cutie pie
scarra dyrus voi boy and shifter
made up a team full of old guard lcs
pros
who were apparently taking this project
seriously
look you cannot you can't argue that the
talent of those players
yeah you want to go for this thresh
[Music]
okay uh in the past has been
he has been some of the you know some of
the best players in the game now coming
back together to dust off their their
competitive uh skills
[Music]
come on oh bop him
holy moly all right this one's name
looking so hot
that was the first thing that came uh
with ease i think for them was
you know the competitive side of wanting
to win
i hit him oh nice okay
wait you got us all killed
and the record may not show it but i
have to think that across the board
it it has reignited their competitive
fires skyrim vader jungle dude do
something
and he pressure [ __ ] god these games are
they're starting to come together a lot
unfortunately
the meme stream dream team as they
called themselves
[Music]
didn't secure a game win during the
entire split
they competed in challenger it
definitely didn't help that they fielded
a team
with three players who were primarily
mid laners
all their games were fairly similar each
player would often win their lane
and then delta fox would just get buried
by their opponent's superior teamwork
in a lot of ways the delta fox
experiment was quintessential cutie pie
they were a team of solid players but
they didn't treat the team seriously
enough
to even win a single game
just as soon as it started the delta fox
experiment finished in winless fashion
it was back to the day-to-day streaming
grind for cutie and his loyal
subscribers
he's arguably more famous than some of
the best lcs players in the world
commands more attention and lives a more
relaxed
lifestyle cutie's popularity shows the
breadth of the esports community
and how game adjacent personalities like
him can
flourish with the right brand tone and
work ethic
which is the ever constant paradigm with
cutie
he's a hard-working self-made
millionaire whose primary means of
making money
is acting like he doesn't care about
anything but having fun
all day long
according to a march 2017 article from
rolling stone
ima cutiepie's streaming career
generates more than
2 million per year in revenue
all that said the pro lifestyle has
changed a lot since cutie's dignitas
days
we've surpassed the era where a team
could attend a tournament
and come home losing money in the new
franchised iteration of the nalcs many
pro players make a livable wage
and they're surrounded by staff whose
job it is to take care of them
and their health i'm a cutie pie left
the wild west of the early days of
league of legends
for the comfort of his living room
gaming setup and a whole lot of money
[ __ ] yeah that's why i'm the best that's
why they pay me the big
bucks baby that's why riot games pays me
to play their champions live on stream
cause they know i make it look good dude
but since his departure the wild west
has undergone a
major facelift which begs the question
did cutie pie leave some potential out
on the rift
cutie was even dethroned from his hard
lock at the top of league of legends
independent streaming charts
tyler1 has been unbanned from the game
and has made
waves in his return to streaming on
january 8th
tyler1 dismantled faker's all-time
individual
league of legends streaming record with
more than 380
000 concurrent viewers
[Music]
he finished the month with more
viewership than cutie
maybe qd could have continued playing
pro and dominated lcs bot lanes like he
always wanted
but his transition to streaming has
definitely worked out well for him
the only thing we know for sure is that
whatever choice was wisest
cutie doesn't care
bye thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button